MACIEK ROZACKI: Hi, welcome
to designing Google Kubernetes
Clusters for Massive
Scale and Performance
session, where we will talk
how Google and Twitter joined
forces to push the limits
of what GKE and Kubernetes
technologies can do.
And we'll also give you
a set of best practices
how to think about
running at large scale
with good reliability
and performance.
I'm Maciek Rozacki.
And I am a product
manager at Google.
REZA MOTAMEDI: Hi,
and I'm Reza Motamedi.
And I'm a software
engineer at Twitter.
MACIEK ROZACKI:
First off, as we're
going to talk about
scalability, let's
nail down the definition
of what it actually means.
If you scan the internet
for explanations
what scalability is, you'll
find numerous definitions.
But they all boil down to a
characteristic or capability
of a system to work with very
significant amount of resources
while still being able to
operate with reliability,
performance, and, essentially,
do the job that the system was
meant to do.
When it comes to Kubernetes, we
expect that in most use cases,
you will want to run on
more than one cluster,
to minimize the risk of any
potential [INAUDIBLE] problems
with any outages, still
being able to operate,
also, large clusters
will simplify many parts
of how you're managing
your software,
starting from easier ability
to manage the microservices
that you're running,
for example, by avoiding
the need for excessive sharding
to reduced operational toil
on managing a fleet of clusters.
There are also scenarios
where simply running
on a single, very
large cluster makes
the most sense, for example, for
highly parallel-izeable batch
jobs.
And last but not least, it's
very useful, in many cases,
to be able to operate in
the lower bound of what
a particular technology can
do, like Kubernetes, and have
a buffer to the
scale limits of it.
So that you can
absorb large spikes.
For example, when you're
running an e-commerce store,
and from time to time, you
have very significant spikes
coming from sales or
events like Black Friday.
When you think about companies
that run at massive scale
and operate huge
infrastructure, Twitter
is going to be one of
the largest in the world.
So let's listen from Reza
how they are maintaining
their infrastructure
and how they
think about its
evolution in the future.
REZA MOTAMEDI: Thanks, Maciek.
I'm going to briefly talk about
the compute infrastructure
Twitter, where we are today,
and where we're going,
and how Kubernetes, in
general, and GKE, specifically,
fits into our plans.
The current main compute
offering at Twitter
is powered by Mesos Cluster
Manager and Aurora Scheduler.
Twitter embraced containers,
starting in 2012.
We used super lightweight
containers with Linux cgroups.
We're not using virtual machine
or Docker level containers.
But we cgroups, we are able to
collocate most of the workloads
on compute infrastructure.
Currently, our compute
offering is mostly on-premise.
But we are extending it
with computing cloud.
Our customers, who
are Twitter engineers,
hire us to manage the lifecycle
of their micro services that,
as a whole, power the Twitter
conversation platform.
There are different categories
of these microservices.
First, there are
stateless applications.
These are mostly fault-tolerant
real-time services that
are very sensitive to latency.
There's also a sizable amount
of offline batch workload,
mostly doing machine learning,
which is also stateless.
Second, we have services
that are kind of stateful,
meaning they keep
some sort of state.
But the state is not
generally durable.
These includes caches,
and search indices,
and other services like that.
These services are not
so forgiving in the face
of failure.
So for them, both performance
and platform reliability
is important.
It is also important to note
that compute infrastructure was
built from the ground
up to be multi-tenant.
So most microservices live
in the same shared pool.
We generally like
multi-tenancy, because it
scales in multiple directions,
from resource efficiency
to operational efficiency,
and also helps us
with capacity management.
The key win for
compute team has been
that all these
different services use
the same configuration,
deployment, debugging,
and management interfaces.
This allows us to
build the tooling
on top of a single platform
that benefits all engineering
teams at Twitter.
In terms of scale, we
run a smaller number
of large Mesos clusters.
Each compute cluster has in the
order of millions of CPU cores,
hundreds of thousands of
containers, tens of thousands
of hosts, and
thousands of services
are running on each cluster.
Our microservices have also
adapted to our large clusters,
meaning that we host more
than a few services that each
have thousands of instances.
In terms of operation,
we manage and maintain
all of our clusters with only 10
to 15 software and reliability
engineers
With that intro, let's see where
Twitter wants to go from here
and how that affects our
plans for the compute team.
There is-- Twitter's
main mission
is to serve the public,
global conversation.
For this, we need to complement
our own on-premise compute
infrastructure with offerings
from public cloud providers.
We already leverage public
cloud for some workloads,
for example, those that benefit
from global distribution.
And we expect this trend
to increase over time.
But as we explore
using the cloud,
we don't want our
customers to deal
with fragmented
compute interfaces,
both in on-premise
and in the cloud.
So our goal is to keep providing
a unified experience to Twitter
engineers.
Also, as we run compute platform
in more environment that
offer new primitives, we
see new opportunities.
We can extend this standard
microservice management layer
that we have today
across an even more
diverse set of services.
This means that we can
onboard the remaining services
onto our platform, for example,
stateful services that are
running on bare metal today.
This will, basically, improve
developers' experience
and productivity
and will eventually
reduce the run the business
costs for everyone at Twitter.
To deal with the potential
additional complexity,
the compute team did a detailed
evaluation and selected
Kubernetes as the
technology that
would power the next generation
Twitter compute platform,
both in cloud and on-premise.
This simplifies our
job, since compute team
needs to be expert and
manage a single technology,
and provides a unified
experience to our customers,
regardless of where their
services are running.
It also gives us the benefit
and support of a vibrant open
source community.
But all of this means
that Kubernetes and GKE
have to scale to Twitter
needs, at least to some extent,
for an acceptable
migration path.
MACIEK ROZACKI: So having heard
the requirements and the needs
of Twitter, we set off to
push the limits of what
our technology
can offer and meet
the requirements of Twitter.
Now, as we set off to
document those requirements,
first, I would like to explain
to you the framework that we
use to document the requirements
and scalability of Kubernetes
in general.
It's a framework that
we use in this context.
But we also recommend
that you leverage it
as you also think about
your architecture,
whether in the initial phases,
or as you're diagnosing
an existing and growing system.
Very frequently, when we
talk about Kubernetes scale,
we use the number of nodes
as a proxy to describe,
in a simplified fashion,
the scale of the cluster.
As your workloads
grow in complexity,
this becomes insufficient.
You may have scenarios where
you don't use too many nodes,
but still hit
scalability problems.
For example, if you excessively
use services in your cluster.
So a better way to think about
your clusters and workloads
is through a
multidimensional hypercube,
where, on each of
the dimensions,
you describe the resources
that your clusters
and workloads need.
And on all of those
dimensions, there
would be an envelope
that wraps all
of the acceptable
configurations.
Where if you don't break
those limits, and don't
go beyond that
envelope, you will
be able to say that
your cluster scales.
So it can use the
resources that you need.
And it gives a healthy
service to your users.
The dimensions that you
can see here on the screen
are just examples.
There is many, many more
that you should account for.
You can find them
in our documentation
of various materials
on the topic.
Here, we want to, essentially,
explain the concept,
how to think about this.
Also, there might
be dimensions that
will be very unique and specific
to your particular workload
with the abstraction
layers and extensions
that you will add
to your cluster.
I would like to
draw your attention
to a couple of characteristics
of the scalability envelope
for Kubernetes that are very
important when you think
about scaling your workloads.
First of all, the
dimensions of that cube
depend on one another.
And moreover, the functions
that describe those dependencies
are not linear and frequently
are somewhat convex.
For example, you
can, theoretically,
run 110 Pods on every node.
But if you grow your
cluster to match, then
with additional nodes, the
acceptable port density
will be very good going down.
And with large
clusters, you will not
be able to go above
30 Pods by node.
The envelope tapers
along each axis, which
means that if you excessively
use a particular resource
on your cluster, then you
will get much less freedom
on all of the other dimensions
with your workloads.
The whole envelope
is bounded, primarily
by the limits of how much
data it can store on etcd.
So there are points that
you cannot just break wit
by stretching the envelope
in just one dimension.
But what's pretty positive about
the behavior of this envelope
is that it's decomposable
into smaller ones.
So there are subsets of
dimensions with which you
can play, independently from
other subsets, and this way,
take a simplified approach to
analyzing your architecture.
So being equipped
with this framework
of describing
requirements, we documented
the needs of Twitter.
We also engaged a few
other design partners.
And we worked with a broader
group of customers and users
who we know could
benefit from operating
at larger scale than currently
supported in Kubernetes.
And based on that
analysis, we came up
with a set of generic
solutions, a portfolio
of use cases, in which
we believe users really
need very large scale.
And we have an understanding
of how the various dependencies
between dimensions need to
be pushed, so that we offer
a very good end-to-end
experience for all
of the workloads that users will
be running on those clusters.
That equipped us to
set a set of targets,
where we want to
push the existing
limits of the technology
forward to meet
the needs of more and
more demanding users.
The primary dimension that we
decided to improve and move
is the number of
nodes up to 15,000,
so three times bigger than
the currently supported limit.
In terms of the number of Pods,
it's half a million by cluster.
We also invested
heavily into improving
the various characteristics
of networking components
in Kubernetes like using
very large services,
and many, many other aspects
of how we run clusters.
You can look for details
in our documentation, where
we publish more
specific information
about each dimension.
To effectively work on pushing
the limits of the technology,
we augmented and extended
our testing framework
through additional
SLIs and SLOs,
extending the test suite with
additional benchmark workloads,
both synthetic and emulating
real customer scenarios.
So that, along the way,
as we are progressing
towards pushing the
limits of the technology,
we are able to
effectively diagnose
where we are on that
journey, and are we already
able to offer highly
reliable and scalable service
to our customers.
The improvements that we
implemented on the journey
come in a few areas.
The main one, which is
probably also the most obvious,
is the fact that the Kubernetes
open source software required
a lot of tuning and improvements
that we implemented and added
to the open source base stack.
There was a lot of
performance optimizations
in various components
all over the code base.
Plus, we added new
APIs, which were
designed from
ground up to support
large scale and big clusters.
We collaborated very
deeply with communities
that manage products on
which Kubernetes depends
on, primarily, here,
etcd and Golang,
to improve the performance
that they offer to Kubernetes.
And we made huge investments
into the integration
layers between
Kubernetes clusters
and GCP's infrastructure.
So a lot of work went into
improved logging and monitoring
pipelines, [INAUDIBLE] scaling
capabilities, networking
components, our control
plane, its ability
to configure and create clusters
and manage data configuration
as they grow in scale.
With all of these improvements
implemented in our tests
to diagnose how it goes, as
we realized that we built
a product that we
believe meets, already,
the needs of our customers,
we went back to Twitter
to get their feedback, whether,
indeed, the high performance
build object of GKE that we
created meets their needs
and will be usable for them.
REZA MOTAMEDI: So
as we heard, Google
has invested in rigorous
scale testing of Kubernetes,
in general, and,
specifically, GKE.
But Twitter was
very much interested
in running its own scale test,
mainly for a couple of reasons.
First, as Maciek
previously mentioned,
each workload profile is unique.
Specifically, for
Twitter workloads,
we were interested
in scaling nodes,
and Pods, and namespaces in a
number of secret dimensions.
But we were not
interested in using
some other resources, like
services and config maps,
at least for now.
This might have not been
a scenario that Google
had scale tested for.
Second, we wanted the
services running on GKE
to work seamlessly
with services running
on our current compute
setup on-premise.
So we decided to use
pluggability and extensibility
features in Kubernetes
and, somewhat heavily,
customize the control plane.
We wanted to run
our own scale tests
to make sure that our
customization will also
stay stable at scale.
To come up with a test plan,
we followed our migration
strategy.
We decided to create
workload that would closely
resemble what Twitter will
eventually run in Kubernetes
on-prem and also in GKE.
We started with what we
are currently running
on Aurora Mesos clusters.
But these clusters are at
least three times larger
than the theoretical maximum
Kubernetes cluster sizes.
So we split the
services and batch
jobs running on a Mesos cluster
across three GKE clusters.
As we mentioned before,
adopting Kubernetes
gave us an opportunity to
run other type of application
on compute as well.
For instance,
stateful applications
that are currently running
as bare metal services
can onboard Kubernetes
as StatefulSets.
And host-level services used
for host-level upgrades, content
distribution, and auditing can
be deployed as daemon sets.
In short, we profiled
what's running
on our current
large data centers.
And we spread them across
smaller Kubernetes clusters.
We wanted to make the
migration to Kubernetes
and cloud seamless
to our engineers.
So we had to customize
Kubernetes' control plane
to make GKE integrate with
our on-premise infrastructure.
We created a set of custom
controllers and admission
webhooks for this.
And I'm going to go over a
subset of the customization
that we did here.
We created a
TwitterSet controller.
A TwitterSet is a hybrid between
a StatefulSet and a deployment,
in Kubernetes terminology.
And we expect all
Twitter microservices
to run as a TwitterSet.
It provides a stable
numerical instance identifier,
similar to StatefulSet.
But it allows us to do batch
updates, similar to how
deployments work.
Each TwitterSet can have
multiple configuration
per workload, which is
mostly used at Twitter
for canarying changes.
And it also provides
us with rollback
on update failure, which is
similar to how Aurora Scheduler
performs its updates today.
We also have a few mutating
and validating webhooks,
mostly to enforce consisting
naming and labeling standards,
and also to enforce
security policies.
For instance, we don't want
to allow foreign Docker images
in our clusters.
We also have a Node
Ready controller,
whose job is basically to
taint nodes that do not run all
the expected daemons on them.
After an analysis on the
current on-premise workload,
we arrived at the
following test targets.
We targeted 15,000
nodes, 600 namespaces.
We added 60,000 secrets that
are not evenly distributed
among all the namespaces.
We estimated that we are going
to run three DaemonSets and 10
StatefulSets, with a
total of 8,000 Pods.
We added around 400 cron jobs.
And this added
another 4,000 Pods.
We finally added
4,000 TwitterSets,
which added another 80,000
Pods to the entire workload.
So what does this
scale test look like?
To minimize the
inter-test interference,
each test run starts
from a blank slate
and goes through
the following step.
We created a new cluster.
We applied Twitter
customizations.
We set up some monitoring.
We applied the workload.
And finally we
collected results.
We measured these results
in terms of service level
objectives, or some SLOs.
We carried some of these SLOs
from our current compute setup,
since our customers are
pretty much used to them.
Although in practice,
these SLOs highly
depend on workload
configuration,
they give us a good
baseline for comparison.
I focus, here, on
two SLOs, here,
that are demonstrated
in this diagram.
Time to Update for TwitterSet,
in short, we call it TTU.
And Time to Running for a Pod,
that is called TTR, in short.
As the name suggests, TTU is the
time it takes for a TwitterSet
to be fully rolled out.
This, obviously, depends
on the batch size
in the rolling update
strategy for the TwitterSet.
In our tests, we
set that to be 20%
of the size of the
workload, which
is a common practice
among our engineers.
We target median TTU to be below
10 minutes for a TwitterSet
of the size of 5,000 replicas.
Time to Running for a Pod is
a time between a Pod update
is requested until it
is considered running
after its update is finished.
As the diagram shows, this
also includes some overhead
for deleting the
old Pod, in addition
to a minimum ready seconds,
which is a setting that you
can set in your Pod spec.
And we set that
to be 10 seconds.
And we targeted this SLO to have
a median of below 40 seconds.
So with that, let's
look at some results.
We have the Time
to Running for Pod
shown as a histogram on the
left, and Time to Update
for different sizes
of TwitterSets
across different measurements
as a scatter plot on the right.
We see that 95% of the Pods
are transitioning to running
in less than two minutes.
Note, that this
actually includes
that 40 second baseline
overhead, 30 seconds for Pod
delete grace period,
and 10 seconds
for minimum ready seconds
in our test setup.
Given the baseline, we see
that mean time to running
is 29 seconds, which
is within bounds.
We also see that the largest
TwitterSet, with 5,000
replicas, takes, on average,
seven minutes to update,
which is, again, within
our 10 minutes SLO bound.
So what did we learn
from all of these tests?
In many cases, we benefited from
sharing our requirements early
on with Google.
This also helped Google with
prioritizing future work.
Another point we
learned was that CRDs
are stored as json, and
not protobuf struts.
This is not very efficient when
you're storing large objects.
But there are a few tricks
that you can use here.
You can break up a large CRD,
if it contains a large array,
into slices.
This is similar to how endpoint
slices work in release version
117.
We also identified some
optimization points
by just tuning
some configuration,
and no code changes.
For instance, we
optimized the client-go
that we use inside our
TwitterSet controller
by setting the qps and burst
to improve its performance.
We also reduced the load
on the webhook server
that we have by scoping the
webhook configuration to only
look at namespace resources.
And this was done to avoid the
flood of node-level events.
So as we wrap up, I'm going
to give it back to Maciek
to talk about some key
recommendations for you
if you are preparing to
run large scale clusters.
MACIEK ROZACKI: Thanks, Reza.
So let's take a look at a
couple of recommended practices
when you think about planning
and running your own systems
at a very large scale.
As you could hear,
it's important
that you test and stretch
both in the planning phase,
and also in later execution,
when you're testing
and building your systems.
You see how you, in particular,
will stretch the envelope.
You need to see how your unique
workload stretches Kubernetes
scalability envelope, and
also see whether you're not
adding any additional
abstraction
layers or specific flavors
to the workload that
would apply only to you.
And so it requires additional
level of validation,
whether it will
operate at large scale.
You can definitely rely
on us to test a set of--
to validate all of
the native components,
and test a set of
representative workloads.
So we really verify
that the infrastructure
layer that you're
going to use is going
to offer high scalability.
When you think about which
aspects of your clusters
and workloads you
should look into,
definitely validate
how are you going
to use all of the native
Kubernetes resources,
whether you're not going to hit
any limits that we documented
and published.
See how all of
the customizations
perform that you
install, especially
monitor what's the load
and impact that they
exert on the API server.
And make sure they operate
effectively at large scale.
See also how your application
itself performs at large scale,
whether your Pods and
Deployments are truly
horizontally scalable,
or there aren't
any bottlenecks that surface
when you run at large scale.
You should also remember that
your clusters, in most cases,
will not exist in void.
They will interact with
other products in your IT
infrastructure.
And they will exert significant
load on some of them.
So proper configuration,
for example,
of databases that your
stateless microservices might
be interacting with
is very important
to think about, both in planning
and, later, in execution
as your systems grow.
To effectively monitor the
health of your systems,
you need to define
a set of SLOs that
build upon the standard ones
that we measure and are closer
to what your end users need and
how they perceive reliability
of your system.
And that will give
you a proper framework
to monitor infrastructure
that you're operating,
and test, and iterate
if you need to make
any improvements into it.
There is one area of your
system's architecture
that I would like to give
you a closer look on,
that we did not cover
before, which is networking.
It's very important that you
look at how your whole network
layers design looks like and
monitor, also, how it evolves
over time as your systems grow
and change, particularly, all
of the load-balancing
concepts, irrespective
whether you're using
Kubernetes Native,
you're using the ones that
are provided by Google Cloud,
or you bring your
own load balancers.
They will have a certain
scalability and performance
characteristics that
you take a look at, like
total number of endpoints, churn
that they support, or other.
You also need to account
for the efficiency
and performance of your DNS.
If you operate and use
DNS at large scale,
definitely use
not local caching.
IP management is very
important to get right,
both for small and
large clusters.
But in large clusters,
that's even more impactful,
as a wrong IP space
configuration can either
lead to your clusters
not being able to grow
beyond certain limits,
or on the other hand,
possibly using
excessive amount of IPs
without the necessity for that.
As last recommendation,
here in this context,
we always recommend that
you use regional clusters
for production.
And for large
scale private ones,
that offers the best
reliability, availability,
and the best network throughput
between the master nodes
and the rest of the cluster.
Whenever you had any problems
or you have any doubts,
please reach out to us.
Your account team
or our support teams
are the first line
of communication
that you can engage with.
And they will involve
broader groups
on Google that will be very
happy to step in and help you
at any stage at which you
might be with your work
at running at large scale.
To wrap up, I wanted to make
a couple of final remarks.
As you could hear, 15,000
nodes are coming to GKE.
We will be rolling them
out on top of release 118.
We'd be very happy if
you decide to use them.
And we are very eager
to hear any feedback
you might have about them.
If you have any
questions, please
feel free to use the Dory.
And also, here on the slide,
you can see our Twitter,
to also send us
a direct message.
With that, we wanted to thank
you and wish you good luck
at running at large scale.
REZA MOTAMEDI: And I
also wanted to thank you
for tuning to our video session.